WELCOME HERE FOR THIS WONDERFUL
HEARING OF OF THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE ON THIS
DAY MARCH TWENTIETH --
WE HAVE SOME NEW MEMBERS --
WITH THIS I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
EVERYONE HERE AND SHARE WITH YOU
THAT UNFORTUNATELY OUR CHAIR
ISN'T ABLE TO BE HERE TODAY HE
WASN'T FEELING SO WELL.
SO WE'LL GET STARTED BECAUSE WE
GOT SOME FOLKS HAVE TO GET TO
OTHER COMMITTEES SOUL DISPENSED
WITH ANY.
OTHER PLEASANTRIES.
AND WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
GREAT.
GREAT ABSENT BIGELOW --
I'M PRESENT.
HERE BERMAN THEIR BERMAN HERE
ONE TIME.
ROW.
ROW HERE COOLEY YOUR COOLEY HERE
COOPER [inaudible]
DALY.
DALY HERE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
HERE GIPSON HERE JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW.
LOW HERE MATHIS [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
QUIRK SILVA HERE.
RE THIS.
REQUEST HERE [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK EVERYONE THAT'S HERE --
AS WE'RE STARTING OFF TODAY I
WOULD LIKE TO START OFF
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AS WE'RE STARTING OFF TODAY AS
WE'VE DONE AND ALL THE
COMMITTEES THIS YEAR WE'RE
STARTING OFF WITH OUR ADOPTING
OUR COMMITTEE RULES THE CHAIR
WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ANY DISCUSSION.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION ON THIS --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
BIGELOW HI.
BIGELOW AYE AYE GEAR CURRY.
RIGHT BERMAN.
BERMAN BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
WE CAN DO THE DAILY ACCOUNT I AM
DALY AYE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA.
GET A SEND.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER MOTION
YEAH.
YEAH LACKEY EACH [inaudible]
LOW.
LOW I'M NOT THIS [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
BECAUSE I DISAGREE WITH THE
ROLLED OUT THAT THE CHAIRMAN MAY
OR MAY NOT HERE BILL I AM GOING
TO BE OPPOSED TO THE RULES TO
THEN BE ENOUGH FOR ME.
LET US KNOW QUIRK SILVA.
FIND.
QUIRK SILVA I READ THIS. THREE
OF US I RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
OKAY LOGIC.
WATCH OUT FOR THE CALL WILL HAVE
THAT -- ON
CALL FOR NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT ITEM WHICH IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR --
WITH THE ENERGY AND A MOTION FOR
APPROVAL OF THE CONSENT.
YEAH THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION --
BY -- WHO
WAS WHO MADE THE MOTION ACTUALLY
MISTER GETS A MADE THE MOTION?
AND QUIRK SILVA MADE THE SECOND.
DO WE HAVE THANK YOU BECAUSE I
DIDN'T SEE THAT.
IS THERE ANY --
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION OF THAT
PARTICULAR ACTION.
I WANT TO MAKE ANY MISTAKES
THERE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OF THE
ROLL -- ITEM
FIVE AB [inaudible]
FOUR FIVE FOUR SIX GREAT.
BIGELOW HI.
BIGELOW I IDEA CURRY.
CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA [inaudible]
BRO.
WROTE I COOLEY MARKET MOVED.
TO GO.
FOR DALY.
I GOT A LETTER.
GARCIA I JUST WANT FOR WHICH
YEAH.
GIPSON I GUESS THAT'S RIGHT
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW.
LOW I MATHIS.
MATHIS HI MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE QUIRK SILVA
[inaudible]
I REQUEST.
REAVIS HIGH RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
THE BILL.
THANK YOU THAT ACTION IS OUT --
WE HAD A COUPLE MEMBERS COME IN
I'D LIKE TO MOVE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE RULES AND HAVE THIS.
I'M SORRY COOPER [inaudible]
MATHIS.
THIS WAS ON THE ASSEMBLY --
GEO RULES REAL WELL AND ALL WHO
HEARD [inaudible]
NOW.
THAT WAS ALREADY TALKED ABOUT
BUT NO WE'RE NOT SO YOU CAN CAST
YOUR VOTE ANYWAY NOW --
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER NO NO NO NO
[inaudible]
MR.
YES MISTER MATHIS.
MATHIS NO.
THIS RUBIO RUBIO [inaudible]
I THEY HAVE A NIGHT SALAS.
OKAY THAT.
THAT THE COMMITTEE RULES HAVE
BEEN ADOPTED SO WE WILL.
MOVE FORWARD UNDER THOSE RULES
FOR THIS --
SESSION.
WITH THAT WE HAVE --
WILL NOW MOVE FORWARD --
TO AGENDA ITEM FIVE WHICH IS
EIGHTY SIX OH NINE MISTER LEVINE
YOU'RE THE FIRST. TO SPEAK
[inaudible]
WE WILL.
MR LIVING YOU HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN
AND CLOSE.
I WOULD IN THE FUTURE FIRST WELL
I WANT TO SEND MY BEST WISHES --
TO THE CHAIRMAN ON A SPEEDY
RECOVERY.
AND AND MISTER CHAIRMAN RECIBE
SIX OH NINE WILL CLARIFY THAT
TAP HANDLES AT BREWERIES AND
TASTING ROOMS ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO BE LABELED UNDER EXISTING
STATUTE INTENDED FOR ON SALE
RETAIL ACTIVITIES WITH ME.
AS A WITNESS I'VE GOT MISTER
CHRIS WALKER REPRESENT A
CALIFORNIA CROPPERS ASSOCIATION
MISTER WALKER YOU HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU IS ANYONE FROM THE
AUDIENCE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR.
ANYONE WISHING JUST BE CAN
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR FROM ANY
MEMBER SEEING.
NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
MISTER LEVINE.
STRICTLY ASPEN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU WOULD YOU CALL THE ROLL.
YOU KNOW MISTER CHAIR HE BROUGHT
A PROBLEM WITH THEM.
AND SOME OF US ARE CURIOUS --
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND.
WE'RE READY TO VOTE SO.
I THINK WE'LL GO STRAIGHT TO THE
ROLL CALL YEAH GOOD I I JUST HAD.
TO I'M PAYING ATTENTION. FIVE
EIGHTY SIX SEVEN NINE MOTION TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
GREAT.
BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE AYE GEAR
CURRY.
YOUR CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA [inaudible]
THROW [inaudible]
RIGHT COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER [inaudible]
DALY HI [inaudible]
GARCIA.
GIPSON FIVE GIPSON NINE JONES
SAWYER [inaudible]
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW HI MATHIS.
MATHIS I AM A WINDOWS.
MELENDEZ AYE QUIRK.
NINE PARTS OF IT I READ THIS.
RIVAS I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
THE BILL GETS OUT.
THANK YOU MISTER LIVING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'D LIKE TO JUST FOR PURPOSES OF
DISPLAY SHOW YOUR PROP
MOMENTARILY MISTER DALY WAS VERY
INTERESTING WELL I CAN SEE IT
FROM HERE BUT YOU'LL SEE IT AS I
WALK AWAY --
I GUESS.
WELL THAT WORKED WELL FOR YOU.
MISS GARCIA --
YOUR NEXT UP AB.
TWO OH EIGHT GREAT WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS --
RUBIO AND MISTER GIBSON SECONDED
THE MOTION YOU HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND THE FLOOR IS YOURS
WOULD YOU LIKE 2% YES AB TILL
EIGHT WOULD SIMPLY INCREASE THE
TOTAL MEMBERSHIP OF THE
CALIFORNIA GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION.
FROM TEN TO TWELVE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
VERY GOOD PRESENTATION.
I SEE YOU DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES BUT LET ME ASK IS
THERE ANYONE.
IN THE AUDIENCE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
ANYONE SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM TWO EIGHTY TWO OH EIGHT
MOTION DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
GRAY.
BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE AYE GEAR
CURRY FIVE YEAR CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
ROW.
ROW HEIGHT COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
DALY AYE DALY AYE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
GARCIA.
GIPSON R. GIPSON AYE JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY I LACKEY HI LOW.
LOW I'M MATHIS.
MATHIS I'LL MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE QUIRK SILVA HI.
I REQUEST.
LEAVE US AYE RUBIO.
THE OUTLINES SALAS.
THAT BILL IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS.
OUR NEXT BILL WILL BE A. B. TWO
OH FIVE MR DAILY.
MR DAILY YOU HAVE A MOTION BY A
MISTER MATHIS.
I THINK I HEARD MISTER BROS ARE
NOT MISTER BERMAN SAY SECOND
THANK YOU FOR THE DO YOU HAVE
ANY MORONS BY THE WAY JUST
BEFORE WE I HAVE NO PROPS BUT I
DO HAVE MISTER CHRIS WALKER WITH
ME THIS IS CRAFT.
CRAFT BREWING GREAT AGAIN OKAY
YEAH.
BUT TO THIS THIS BILL SIMPLY
UPDATES STATE LAW TO REFLECT
CHANGES IN FEDERAL LAW THAT WERE
MADE THIRTEEN YEARS AGO.
REGARDING A WHAT CAN BE ADDED TO
BEER.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH IT.
VERY THOROUGH VERY COMPLETE
WHICH WOULD JUST LIKE TO ADD
ANYTHING OF VALUE MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS A COMMITTEE --
THIS IS SIMPLY ALLOWING THE SAME
INGREDIENTS AT THE FEDERAL LAW
ALLOWS WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE FROM THE
AUDIENCE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
SAYING NINE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS ACTION.
YES SIR PLEASE.
COME FORWARD AND GIVE YOUR NAME
AND WHO YOU REPRESENT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE A MIKE SKIPPER
REPRESENTING ALCOHOL JUSTICE IN
THE CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE.
ACTUALLY I DO HAVE A PROP.
WHICH IS A SMALL BOTTLE OF
DISTILLED SPIRITS MADE FROM
HONEY.
IT'S 71% PROOF.
AND WHAT WE FEAR IS THAT THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW --
NOT JUST THE CRAFT BREWERS BUT
ANYONE WHO HAS --
AN ABUNDANCE OF ANY KIND OF
FRUIT -- TO
PUT TOGETHER A PRODUCT THAT WILL
APPEAL TO YOUTH --
BY BEING FRUITY AND SWEET AN
INEXPENSIVE AND AVAILABLE IN ANY
QUARTER --
GROCERY STORE OR SEVEN ELEVEN SO
CALLED ALCO POPS.
AND FOR THAT REASON TO IT COULD
EXPAND.
THE AVAILABILITY OF YOUTH
ATTRACTIVE PRODUCTS AND WE
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE AND THE SPONSOR
THE BILL.
AND AS FOR A NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOES ANYONE
ELSE WISH TO ADDRESSES
NONTRADITIONAL --
DOES THE AUTHOR WANT TO ADDRESS
ANY CONCERNS RAISED BY THE YEAH
ALL DEFERRED TO MISTER WALKER IF
YOU CHOOSE TO RESPOND.
YES MAKE SURE JUST BRIEFLY --
BEER HAS BEEN BREWED WITH HONEY
AND FRUIT FOR LITERALLY
THOUSANDS OF YEARS --
THIS IS NOT AN ALCOPOP.
THIS IS BEER PRODUCTS THESE ARE
PURE PRODUCTS THEY'RE ALLOWED BY
THE FEDERAL.
OF FEDERAL LAW AND REGULATION
123409% OF THE ALCOHOL CONTENT
CAN COME FROM FROM MENTAL SHOCK
FERMENTABLE SUGARS THAT ARE NOT
BARLEY -- SO
THE FEDS HAVE ALREADY GONE
THROUGH THIS HI THIS IS NOT AN
ALCO POP.
TYPE OF REGULATION THIS IS ABOUT
BEER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE AUTHOR
[inaudible]
DO.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND SECRETARY.
I DON'T PLAN.
EIGHTY TWO OH FIVE MOTION TO
PASS RATE.
BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE AYE HERE
CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BERMAN BONTA.
BY BONTA NINE BRO.
ROW RIGHT COOLEY AYE.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
DALY HI DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA.
GIPSON R. GIPSON NINE JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY.
LACKEY HI LO.
LO HI MATHIS.
THIS ISLAND AS MELENDEZ AYE
QUIRK SILVA HI.
PARTS OF I REQUEST.
RE BEST AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
MS CURRIE IS ANNOYING YOU CAN
CALL.
THE BILL IS OUT MISTER DALY
COULD THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THIS ACCURATE CURRY.
AB.
FOUR THREE SIX I KNOW YOU HAVE A
WONDERFUL PRESENTATION AND YOU
MAY HAVE SOME FOLKS WITH YOU
TODAY [inaudible]
OR NOT.
SO MISTER GIBSON --
MADE A MOTION AND TO AND A
SECOND BY MISTER BERMAN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I WILL QUICKLY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS JUST
THIS IS --
AB FOR THIRTY SIX IS A DISTRICT
BILL THAT ALLOWS THE HISTORIC
NAPA VALLEY OPERA HOUSE TO
DEVELOP ADVERTISING SPONSORSHIPS
WITH ALCOHOL MANUFACTURERS
INCLUDING LOCAL WINE MAKERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
IN WITH ME I HAVE --
TO PEOPLE TO TESTIFY THE MAKE IT
SHORT.
WHICH I WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST.
ATOMIC TOMORROW HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF NAPA IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL [inaudible]
VERY SHORT.
DJ SMITH CHAIR OF THE NAPA
VALLEY OPERA HOUSE.
SOME WOMEN CRAWLING --
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
CAN TESSLER MANAGING DIRECTOR
BLUE NOTE NAPA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
IS OR ANYONE FROM THE AUDIENCE --
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
DOES ANY MEMBER HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
WOULD YOU CALL THE ROLL.
I DON'T THREE EIGHTY FOUR THREE
THREE SIX DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS GRAY.
BIGELOW.
AYE BIGELOW AYE.
HI [inaudible]
I BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BONTA AYE BRO.
BRO AYE COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
COOPER.
DALY I DALY AND GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
GARCIA.
GET SENT FIVE GIPSON AYE JONES
SAWYER [inaudible]
LACKEY.
LACKEY HI LOW.
LOW HI MATHIS.
MATHIS I MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA HI
FOR SOME I READ THIS.
LEAVE US AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
YOU DID WELL YOUR BILL IS OUT
CONGRATULATIONS.
WE CAN WE CALL THE ROLL OVER.
WICKS YEAH WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ANOTHER. FIVE
SIX MINUTES SO WE CAN GET ALL
THE MEMBERS THAT WERE ABSENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY HOLD ON HOLD ON EVERYBODY.
WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL JUST GO
DOWN THE LIST AND WE'LL HAVE THE
SECRETARY CALL YOUR NAMES SO
THAT WE CAN DO THE OUT ON?
SO [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
SO WE'LL START.
START WITH THE RULES VOTE --
WE HAD AN ACTION FOR THE
COMMITTEE RULES.
SO IF YOU'LL CALL THE ROLL ON
THE COMMITTEE RULES.
ADOPTION OF COMMITTEE ROLES.
ON AT BONTA [inaudible]
BONTA I GALLAGHER NO.
GALLAGHER NOW GARCIA
[inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS AYE.
YEAH THAT'S WHAT YEAH THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT ACTION WILL BE. TWENTY
HAVE A PRINTER AND EIGHTY TWO OH
WAIT OKAY AB TWO AWAY CRISTINA
GARCIA.
CONTACT.
BONTA HI COOPER.
GALLAGHER.
HI GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA
[inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS I AB [inaudible]
TWO OH FIVE UBER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS HI.
CONSENT CALENDAR I BEAT AB FIVE
FOUR SIX ITEM [inaudible]
FOR BERMAN [inaudible]
WAS HIGH [inaudible]
BONTA.
BONTA AYE COOPER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA
[inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
LACKEY.
RUBY.
NO NO NO THAT'S FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ON YOUR AND I LACKEY I
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS I MATHIS ALRIGHT.
YOU WERE ALREADY DOWN NINE ON
THAT.
ONE OKAY THAT'S WHAT I WANT
[inaudible]
TO THAT IT.
WE AT SIX OH NINE LEVY YEAH. TWO
SEVEN SIX YES --
ITEM FIVE SIX AB SIX OH NINE
BONTA.
BONTA I COOPER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA
[inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
SALAS SALAS AYE.
WE ARE FOR MORE BILL THAT'LL BE
A. B..
FOUR THREE SIX THREE IT WAS
NUMBER.
THREE ITEM THREE EIGHTY FOUR
THREE SIXTY PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
SALAS.
SALAS I I THINK THE BOTTOM ALL
GO BACK TO THE COMMITTED RULES
THAT WE HAVE.
IS TO LET [inaudible] ONE OF WE
HAD HIM.
YEAH.
OKAY.
YEAH I WAS JUST GO AHEAD MAJOR
AND SOME OKAY OKAY.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.
WHAT --
JONES SAWYER IS RIGHT
[inaudible]
ALWAYS PRESENT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
WHICH BELIEVE